l'otan a 70 ans mais au juste c'est quoi
le temps voilà une bonne question
l'otan au t1 n comme organisation du
traité atlantique nord
mais genre encore et bien c'est une
alliance militaire qui a pour but
d'éviter la guerre et de se défendre
mutuellement en cas d'agression nous
sommes de la famille nous sommes dans la
famille à sa création en 1949
ils sont douze pays a signé sous l'égide
des états unis belgique canada danemark
france islande italie luxembourg norvège
pays bas portugal et royaume uni des
pays de l'atlantique nord le rival de
l'otan c'est le bloc soviétique le pacte
de varsovie
constituée en 1955 en pleine guerre
froide
il faut montrer qui est le plus fort
l'otan exhibe alors ses longues fusée et
ses avions atomique nous pourront
décoller en moins de deux minutes à la
france et de la partie jusqu'en 1966 le
président de gaulle décide de quitter le
commandement intégré de l'otan
un geste d'indépendance envers les états
unis et l'occident ne se trouve plus
actuellement menacés comme l'était en
vérité la france participent aux
opérations
mais base aux décisions après la chute
du bloc soviétique en 1991
l'alliance atlantique fait de la gestion
de crise en bosnie en 1994
c'est la première opération de combat de
l'organisation à la durée de 10 ans
autre mission de l'otan défendre les
copains pour tous surtout quand c'est le
plus puissant qui est attaqué après les
attentats du 11 septembre 2001 l'otan se
déploie en afghanistan contre le
terrorisme c'est sa mission la plus
longue jusqu'en 2014
en 2009 nicolas sarkozy annonce le
retour de la france dans le commandement
intégré de l'otan la france sera plus
influents pourquoi parce que les absents
ont toujours tort au long de son
histoire l'otan s'étaient tendues fils
sont désormais 29 membres dont le
dernier le monténégro a été accueilli en
[Musique]